Hello, everybody,
My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to the Museum of Simulation Technology.
Now this game was told to me by Ethan of Crank Gameplays -
who has the crankiest crew in the West.
And this game might be a little different than you're expecting, because,
* INHALES *
It's a little bit odd.
It may seem simplistic at first,
and I don't know too many details about the gameplay itself.
But I do know about the core fundamental
aspect of the game.
Which is,
to, uh,
manipulate your environment.
WELCOME to the Museum of Simulation Technology!!!!!!
Now, you may see these giant obelisks in the distance, different landmarks, and stuff.
But what makes it really interesting,
is when you grab them,
they... uh...
they change their size,
and... uh...
Th-this isn't an illusion!
If I go over here,
and I walk over to this thing.
It is legitimately huge.
Right now, it's-it's huge.
But if I grab it,
it's, uh,
it's no longer huge,
and that's how the game works.
It's like some weird,
weird dynamic.
That's huuge and in the distance.
Oh, wait. No, it's not. It's right here and tiny.
Oh, look at that!
It's fricking tiny.
Or is it fricking, gigantic?
Which it is.
Oh, I can make it bigger than that.
Well, I can make it bigger than that.
Huh, Boink!
SHABOOM!
Wait, we can go bigger...
we can go bigger, we can go bigger.
AAAUUUUHHHH......
BOOM!
Oh, is that-
is that tiny itty bitty-
is that- is that itty bitty Lady Liberty over there?
It might be hard for-
Oh,
God, that's tiny.
Oh, whoops.
Well, I done goofed on that one. I don't how to-
fix that.
Oh, boy.
Alright,
well, it's a little bigger than it was.
Yeesh,
I don't know how to make that any smaller.
Let's see if I can make this any bigger.
Shoom!
Oh, it's too big to FIT!
Oh, no!
Enough goofing around here.
So, this is what the fundamental principle of the game is:
it's about changing the dynamic sizes of these objects.
Including, this one.
SHEEEEEEUURRRMMMM
BOOM! Okay,
So, anyway-
So, I don-
That's the only part I know about the game,
and that's what really blew my mind when I heard about this game.
Oh...
Ohhhh...
I get to be puzzled!
Mini kitchen appliances exhibit.
OHH, it's delightful!
Or, is it?
Or, is it gigantic?
Oh, that's so cool!
Okay, so I gotta like...
like, from-
I-I gotta move back.
and then, suddenly, it's going to be as big as I need it to be.
Or, bigger!
Oh, that's so cool! How high can I jump here?
Okay, so this is workable.
So then I just gotta make everything that I need.
Up to the staircase- to the exit,
and that's the basic principle of the game.
And that's SO FASINATING!
Like, I know it's probably just a clever
programming trick.
But, even so,
just because it's a clever programming trick,
does not mean that's fricken fascinating
Like, that's legitimately...
fascinating!
Oh, no, I'm blocked from it.
Why am I bloocked?
But, still! Oh, my God, that's so cool!
It's just like,
I don't know.
It's something like that. It's clever gaming mechanics wrapped in a wrapper,
that does not seem that convoluted.
This seems like that simplistic graphics in gameplay,
but, even so...
Oh,
hi Mona Lisa.
Can you-
Oh, maybe I can build a ramp, or something.
ooooooOOOOHHHHH! BOINK!
Ooh...
Not quite enough.
There we go.
Oh!
Okay,
so, I got the slant.
I just gotta make it bigger.
Mona Lisa,
come here.
Ooooooh...
Eh-YUP!
Is that going to work for me?
EH-YUP!
Excuse me.
Pardon me.
Scuse me.
PAARDON MEE!
PaRdOn MeEeE!
Thank you :)
And just like that, you use the entire environment to make your way-
OOOH-AAAAH!
FUUUCKING fuck.
And just like THAT, you use the entire-
OOHH-AH!
FUCKING, GOD, DAMN IT!
And just like that, you use the entire momentum to be able move through the level.
And, THUSLY,
If I've got this right.
So, can I take this one?
Yes, I can.
Huuu-ah!
*farting noise*
BLEAA-
*more farting noises*
Ohh, that's AWESOME!
That's AWESOME!
But, it kind of got fubber-nucked
Can you not be fubber-nucked?
Alright, well, that's blocked.
Literally.
No, no, no.
Oh, God, damn it.
WELL, shitty tits.
Alright, we're working with something here.
UUUGH, so close!
Wait, I might be able to work with this.
I might've gotten this on the first go,
and I didn't realize it.
EH-YUP!
AOOOI! Okay,
easy peasy, lemon squeeze me.
Okay,
So I ju-
woah!
That is a pit of death!
That's a big ass pit of death!
Am I supposed to use that to my advantage, or something?
Oh, grab!
Oh, boy.
That's going to work, is it?
What if I make SO BIG!
FUCK, I MADE IT TINY!
God, damn it!
OH, the momentum is a little stanky on here.
God, damn it.
Alright, fine. I'll restart.
Oh, it checkpointed me. That's awfully convenient of it.
Okay, so I just gotta make
it big enough -
BOINK
- that it'll... LAND...
SHHEIIT!
Lost that one.
Grab!
You're big now!
You're big now.
Woah!
GRAAB!
You're ridiculously big now!
Whoa, how close am I to the edge?
WHOA!
OH, BOY!
That's too big!
That's WAY too big!
Oh, boy!
OH, BOY!
AHHHH, shit! It went right down the hole.
God, damn it.
That's more like it.
OHHHHH-AH!
GOD, DAMN IT! RIGHT IN THE HOLE!
Across the briidge!
RIGHT IN THE GOD DAMN HOLE!
AHHHHH!
Oh, that's eas- you didn't even need it!
You just jumped across.
Well,
alright then,
I'm dumb.
I love the smoooth jazz.
Oh,
maybe I can use this.
Like, what if I am able to use this fan?
And, it will blow me?
Is it blowing me?
Can you blow me harder?
Please.
Pretty, please?
That's all I've ever wanted.
Can I tip it?
Come on! Tip, baby!
Tip for me!
Oh, shit! My face!
AAGGH! God, damn it.
Get off my head.
OOOOOH!
OOOOHHH!
Well, that was awfully convenient. Thank you, I didn't know I could do that.
I didn't even consider that to be an option!
Woah...
If an object is outlined in blue...
Right-click to rotate.
Oh, shit.
Yes, please.
Oh, come on!
Get me into space!
I wanna go to SPACE!
That's not the moon...
Oh, well.
Whatever,
it's good enough.
God, damn it, LET ME OOON!
Not the way I want it to rotate.
Like, thusly!
Whoooa,
Whoa!
Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa!
Blocked?
God, damn it.
Just, too big!
That might be too honkin huuge.
Ah!
WHOA!
OH!
That's a bigon!
Oh, that's a bigon.
Awe, I'm not going to be able to get to the tip top of that, though.
Face it uup!
Boink!
Oh, boy!
That's really big!
OOH! That's too big!
Oh, boy!
I made that big!
HOOOH! I made that big!
Woah, let's just restart that one.
Maaaybe...
That's a pretty steep grade, though.
I don't know if I will make that one.
That's, like, really steep.
OH, MY GOD! MAYBE I CAN!
OOOOH! Shitty tits.
HEAH!
Come on! Come on! Come on!
Get it! GET IT!
Oh, I'm jumping so much!
Gee, I don't know about this one.
Yee! Eh! Eh-yeh-yeh-yay
I-yi-yi
I-yi
ANY MINUTE NOW!
Oh, boy!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Slow, slow, slow, slow, slow!
Don't fail me now!
Don't fail me...
NOW!
Woe!
*gibberish*
Okay!
Was I supposed to that?
I don't know if I was supposed to do that.
But I did that.
Oh...
So, um, uh...
Ay,
alrighty then!
Wha- ugh, what do I do and where do I go?
And let's not momentum our way off of this thing.
Let's just, ugh...
you know...
OH, come on!
Really?
Is there no-
no exit?
What?
Oh, hey.
Well, that's weird.
Okay, goodbye then, I guess.
Uh, ohh...
Uh, OH...
Ohhhhh...
OHHHH!
What the hell?
Wait a minute...
I didn't even know you could grab that!
Whaaat?
Whaaaat?
WHAAAT?
Is that the exit?
Whaa-
Hoooooh...
Oh, man!
Oh, okay.
I was going the wrong way the WHOLE time.
Oooh, MY God.
Alright, I think that's good enough. I think I can slide right through there.
Holy, shit...
I didn't even know-
I did not know you could grab the moon there.
I was being a big, dumb, idiot.
Hooly, shit...
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
Go-AH OH MY
GAAWD!
OH MY, GAAWD!
OH, THAT'S awesome.
HHH-UUGH!
Not okay.
They're now putting mirrors in this bullshit,
and I'm not okay with this.
WOOOOOE, BOY-O!
HHHHHOOOH, boy-o.
Oh, boy-o.
OOOOOHHH!
WHAT THE FUUCK?
OH, HI!
What's up there?
OOOOOH!
God, I'm in a different uni- OH MY GOOD!
HH-UUGH!
OH, boy!
OHH, boy!
Oh, God. This place is so big!
Oh, I didn't mean for this to happen!
Oh, I need to make it smaller!
Not bigger!
This needs to be...
fffffflllippin' huge!
And this,
is...
perfect- AHHH!
There we go.
So this is gotta be-
not quite yet, but...
there we go.
ANNND...
SHOOP!
Okay,
WAAAI-
Not yet, not yet.
Okay, get down there.
SHABOOSKI!
Okay that perfectly nor- WOAH!
Perfectly normal sized.
What happens when I make this
Unbelievably huge.
I guess, I can't.
Okay, I get it.
I get it, I get it!
Uggh...
Okay,
alright,
just like that.
That's big.
This is normal.
Shoosh...
OH, MY GOD!
OH, I LOVE IT
I love it!
I might be too big!
NOPE!
Just the right size.  (MARRK)
AWE, THAT'S IT!
OHAWWWE
Okay,
so, this is just a demo
of a game that's going to be coming out later.
This is a demo
that just shows a lot of potential in the uniqueness of what can be done in a game.
It's kind of like-
That last bit was kind of Portal-esque,
but just the mechanic of changing the shape based on perspective, kind of like,
warps your brain on what actually is reality.
It's fucking insane, but I love it.
So,
thank you, everybody, so much for watching!
Hope you enjoyed this. Let me know what you think of it down in the comments below,
and I'll try to link to the game, in the description if you wanna try it for yourself.
So, thank you, everybody, so much for watching!
And, as always...
I will see you,
in the next video!
BUH-BYEE!
[Outro music] SUBSCRIBE TO MARKIPLIER AND HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY!!!!!!